back then when my dad was making me do
all this stuff i had no idea why he was
making me do it uh but when i got older
obviously i've
i know why he wanted me to be a lot more
disciplined he wanted me to be a hard
worker uh and no excuse this type of of
relationship
you either do it or do it you know it
was kind of that attitude i think when i
got to the yankees they they kind of
liked that leadership of me of being a
hard worker being the last one on the
field
being the last one out of the clubhouse
because of things that you're doing
during you know during the year that
you feel uh really really comfortable
about you know staying on that track and
and being that focused so i think it
helped me a lot that approach definitely
pays off in a town like new york
your father was a scout for major league
baseball your love for the game really
came from him uh baseball this sport
however has lost some of its shine in
the last 20 years in that there's a lot
of criticism that the game is really
long or it's really boring and it hasn't
adapted to the times what do you think
of that criticism you know what uh
the the nowadays there's so much
strategy going on the
the managers the you know the coaches
are are so much prepared that they have
an idea what to do you know the bullpen
is so important for winning ball games
uh you see them the yankees that we won
you know we had a great bullpen you
bring guys in to try to face a guy
so that's why i think it's it's just a
little bit just a little bit longer but
it's just the strategy that goes behind
a winning a ballgame that makes it a
little bit long so should mlb change
that do you think it needs to be changed
i don't think so i don't think so i
think it would be really really tough to
change you know what uh the way of how
to win a ball game i don't think that
will ever change in fact with more data
it might just even get more complicated
a little bit more complicated they're
gonna try to you know speed it up a
little bit and try to get the pitcher to
throw a little faster and the hitter not
to leave the batter's box so
there's a lot of routine that the hitter
goes through the picture goes through
that you're trying to minimize now right
right well it obviously starts with kids
i mean you loved baseball as a kid but a
lot of kids are now playing other sports
like lacrosse like soccer how do you get
kids interested in baseball now it's
that's my biggest problem with kids now
uh the discipline if you're going to
enjoy something if you're going to
follow something there's got to be some
kind of
you know routine and there's got to be
some kind of discipline and priority
you know about the sport that you play
nowadays kids are all over the place
there's so much stuff to do
that kids don't know you know
i was a coach of jv team
this past
fall and
i'm in spring and
the kids there's kids who have a lot of
talent but they have no idea of how you
know to
you know to follow their dream